thanks all of you for joining my uh
presentation today about the early
identification of target candidates for
pancreatic adenocarcinoma immunotherapy
as probably all of you are aware car
t-cell therapies really have gained
a lot of interest because of their
tremendous efficacies in treating in
particular hematopoietic malignancies
over the last years a very prominent
example being all right now also cd19
directly car t cells have gained fda
approval recently
and really show a nice example of
cellular immunotherapy efficacy
however so far this success is really
limited to hematopoietic malignancies
such as al and some others whereas
there's very limited success in treating
solid tumors and that has a
range of reasons such as a very
immunosuppressive immune micro
environment
but also the lack of known target
structures which you have for example
here in all there is the lineage marker
cd90 that is expressed on almost all of
the tumor cells in many of or most of
the patients but this is not the case
when you have solid tumors and in
particular also these healthy cells
which are also targeted because they
express cd19 are actually dispensable
meaning the cartesians that eradicate
the tumor cells and also eradicate the
healthy b cells um is still an option
because you can do this by uh a
therapy intervention that can still um
yeah be tolerated well by the patients
and that is not the cases in many solid
tumors because the uh the structures
that i expressed on the solid tumor
epithelial cells are also expressed on
cells of other healthy organs that are
not dispensable
so let's briefly go into the principle
of car t-cell therapies so this here is
shown for an autologous setting where
the patient is actually undergoing a
leukopheresis the t cells are separated
from the leukopheresis and are then
ex-vivo modified genetically engineered
to express the car or the chimeric
antigen receptor on the surface this is
mostly done by lentivirus but also mrna
and other methods can be applied
afterwards the cells are further
activated and expanded to huge amounts
which are then re-infused back into the
patient where the cartesets can
efficiently migrate to the tumor cells
and then kill them by a
recognition of the cell surface molecule
expressed on the cancer cell by the car
and then afterwards cytokine release and
also active killing of the cancer cells
and on the right hand side you can also
see a little bit of differences between
a t-cell receptor mediated and car
mediated
targeting
so both have advantages and
disadvantages for example the car is
very efficient in treating
cell surface marker-based
approaches because it is not restricted
to mhc molecules so it's independent on
the haplotype of the patient so
basically the same targets can be
applied that you can also apply by
biologics such as antibodies or bytes
however the disadvantage is of course
that you can only target cell surface
structures whereas for t cell receptors
you can also target intracellular
structures
and even mutated antigens because they
are presented in mhc fashion so today i
will focus purely on car t cells
and as mentioned one of the major
bottlenecks is the strategy for
identification of the best therapeutic
targets which have to be cell surface
targets and we over the last couple of
years have really worked a lot on this
for different tumor indications today as
mentioned the focus on pancreatic
ductile adenocarcinoma
and we have developed this strategy here
where we start with solid tissues either
from patient derived
mouse models xenograft models or from
primary human specimens and as jana
already pointed out did this here by
high throughput screening of cell
surface antigens by flow cytometry in
order to narrow down the amount of
markers that are of interest and then do
a further spatial identification of
these
marker candidates let's say in the
tissue context and this leads to the
selection of top candidates for further
downstream functional evaluation
so let's go into this a little bit more
in deep
because here you see also a little bit
more the the initial early workflow and
where we started screening of about 400
antibodies for binding on pancreatic
tumor cells and therefore we have also
used 19 different patient graft models
and this has advantages here tumor
material is not limiting meaning that
you can easily do flow cytometry based
screenings and do parallel analysis of
single samples by screening antibody
whereas in the second course when you
then want to go more into the validation
mode
and you want to do this on primary tumor
but also in particular on healthy tissue
specimens in order to identify potential
on target of tumor toxicities really the
tissue becomes the limiting factor and
here we have done sequential screening
by immunofluorescence and i will also
briefly talk about this later
but first of all let's talk about the
icon the
screening by flow cytometry
see again we splitted this up as
mentioned we started with pdx model
having hundreds of millions of cells
and then we applied these screening
plates that we provide among screening
plates and then also uh
narrowed the
number down to a more com more narrower
data set and then i also screened many
more pdx models again and this all was
done by flow cytometry and then after
narrowing down the marker of candidates
we have also worked even with flow
cytometry with primary tissue specimens
which were coming from surgical
resections of primary tumors and then
have also stained them by flow cytometry
so of course when you want to do flow
cytometry based screening you have to
have a very efficient way to get a
single suspension and that can be very
tough from certain tumor types such as
pancreatic cancer which uses very
desmoplastic and very tough
and so basically you have two goals the
first goal is very obvious you want to
disrupt the exocellular matrix and
salitesian components without destroying
integrity of your cell membrane and for
this enzymatic digestion is usually most
efficient however second goal that is
often not really well considered is that
you want to preserve your cell surface
target candidates of course because if
you lose a lot of these markers just by
using crude or aggressive proteases in
the first hand step then you would also
have a lot of false negatives that you
for sure want to avoid and for this
mechanical disruption usually is the
method of choice however
many cells which are really well
associated in the tissue such as the
epithelial tumor cells cannot be derived
efficiently only by mechanical
dissociation usually and most deficient
is the combination of both the
mechanical and enzymatic treatment and
for this already many years ago we have
developed optimized solutions uh in our
tumor dissociation kits for human but
also for mouse where you can get
actually very nice single cell
suspensions of highly viable tumor cells
and also all the other compartments that
you have in the tumor and these cells
are also show improved functionality and
according to the second goal i mentioned
the preservation of key cell surface
antigens and we could actually show by
screening more than 200 epitopes that we
have tested on human and mouse tumors
after on the association that only about
five percent of these markers are
affected by our enzyme combination if
you compare this to very aggressive
enzymes to trypsin or
this space usually you see that more
than 50 percent are affected and because
we are using highly purified enzymes and
a mixture of certain enzymes we can
exactly control the um the reactivity
let's say of these enzymes and we know
that these about five percent
sensitivities come from and some are so
if you reduce this you can preserve all
the markers that you uh that you have
so you
can refer to these lists can see if your
mark of choice is sensitive or not so
you do not have to do this empirically
in-house and then you can
follow this up reduce enzyme r if
there's a marker actually you're
interested in and that you want to
analyze
and this is the data from these initial
screenings and
for the pdx models this is just a
snapshot because i mentioned we split
many more markers that is just example
data so what you want to actually get
here is you only have human tumor cells
of course because all the other cells
are mouse tissue so you can go for on
two more binding but you cannot evaluate
off tumor binding of course so in the
first screening we really go for the
specificity on the tumor and choose
markers that are highly expressed on the
human tumor cells in this setting and
then secondly when we go to primary
human tissues you can then of course um
map the marker expression on your tumor
cells but you can also compare it to the
expression for example on immune cells
and other cells that are still present
in the tumor tissue and by this then
together with bioinformatic safety
ranking you can come to a more close
number of markers that are serving as
potential target candidates
so then that brings you to the second
step where you maybe want to then uh
further analyze and validate your target
candidates on primary adenocarcinomas
but also on normal adjacent tissue and
health situation microarrays and as
mentioned here the tissue specimens are
really the limiting factor so you have
to go for another method and that is uh
usually immunofluorescence multiplex
immunofluorescence either if you uh
compare standard microscopy which easily
can be done in five plex uh or even some
more but that has to be
tremendously validated uh however in
this five packs usually you cannot then
always screen five targets candidates
because you also want to have an idea
about the lineages that you have so you
usually stain all the immune cells and
tumor sets to see really the core
expression of your market of interest so
if you want to stain 100 markers you
have to do with 30 to 50 uh serial
sections
and
as each section is really
similar but still
a little bit different you completely
lose then the single cell information
and that is in particular important if
you want to do correlation analysis
which targets are co-expressed on which
cells
and for this we have developed the
maxima technology and that is a cyclic
immunofluorescence staining method where
you can really go
until several hundred plex marker
analysis on the very same tissue section
so keeping the single cell resolution of
course
and by this you can then of course also
apply the lineage markers and all of
your target candidates in one run and
all stain them on the very same tissue
section
and this is just one example here from
the markets that were interesting from
the flow cytometry and what you see here
in the primary pancreatic ductual
adenocarcinoma and just to
focus on on a few here you see of course
that some
are tumors specific like cd 318 where
you see really a nice correlation of the
epithelial cytokeratin signal and our
markov interest whereas others as
expected like cd59 are not too much
specific so they are expressed on tumor
cells but also on stromal cells and
endothelial cells so you can then
exclude such markers from further
analysis
and this of course is very helpful on
the tumor tissue already however
also you want to see the potential on
target of tumor toxicity in other organs
and therefore you can then also use
healthy tissue microarrays like here
where you see again cd 318 being nicely
expressed on pancreatic cancer but not
on the other tissues there's a slight
background expression in the colon but
this is mostly in a mucous region
whereas for example for t span8 you see
a strong expression in the pancreatic
cancer sample but also very strong
expression in the colon so this target
for sure needs further evaluation but
actually this is very similar for other
targets such as ca which are already
under clinical evaluation and there are
other methods to overcome potential
toxicity such as different routes of
injection or safety switches within the
car t cells
so then upon
having enough validation and confidence
in your target candidates you can go on
for functional evaluation and first of
all you have to then clone this into an
array of car constructs because still so
far it is not possible to purely predict
what car configuration would be optimal
for your target candidate so of course
you can talk about the signaling domains
the transmember intermediates but one
very particular case is also the spacer
domain because for many binders you do
not know where your epitope of binding
is located is it very membrane proximal
or is it very membrane distal and in
order to resemble more or less
immunological synapse you need to really
get the right spacer length in order to
target shorter or longer targets
and therefore we have done so we have
cloned scfvs and put them in into the
card context and then that function
analysis and this is just one example
how this works so we have transduced t
cells with our car constructs and here
you see a mock control so mock
transfused with an irrelevant car or
even gfp
or also car t cells and here you see a
gfp labeled tumor cells and then when
you add the um the car t cells or the
mock t cells and then you um
start the killing essay you see that the
car t sets very fast and efficiently
eradicate the tumor cells whereas the
mock t cells cannot do so and this can
also be quantified of course and as you
can see here so you see that some cars
are highly efficient some are
intermediate efficient
and some also non-functional and next to
the pure killing kinetics of course what
is also very interesting is to get into
the further car phenotyping and this
again is of course done by flow
cytometry with checking for activation
and exhaustion markers such as pd1 but
also a cytokine release
such as interferon gamma but also many
more so here we're using our maxplex
flow essay to really imperially analyze
a lot of different cytokines in the
supernatant of such co-cultures
so this is nice but this is all done on
based on functionality on um
cell lines tumor cellulites that have
been cultured for decades and not really
resemble the heterogeneity that you find
in primary tumors so we were wondering
really what about the efficacy on
primary cells coming from patient
graphic xenographs or also primary
tumors and that of course complicates
the whole method because you cannot
start here where you have your t cell
and tumor cell culture and then can go
directly into a functional killing essay
and to phenotyping but you have to start
much earlier with the solid tissue
and again the first step would be sample
preparation i will not go into this
again because we already discussed it so
but then you have two additional steps
first of all you have to isolate your
cells of choice so your tumor cells and
then you have to culture them
because in many cases you might not have
enough material from the beginning so
you might want to at least short-term
expand the tumor cells for your
functional assays but also
you
have to plate them in order to do these
killing assays and that is not so
trivial when you work with primary tumor
cells
so let's start with the isolation of
your target cells and
at milton we have
developed a comprehensive workflows uh
starting from all different uh materials
oxenographic tumors mouse tumors or
human tumors and then isolate your tumor
cells as today i would only go into
xenograft and human tumors but the
principle is the same for all of them
so let's talk about the xenografts first
and here let's say it's a more or less
easy solution because you have human
tumor cells in a mouse context so what
you want to do is you want to remove all
the mouse cells in order to isolate your
tumor cells and therefore we have done a
cell surface marker screening and have
coupled an array of antibodies to
paramagnetic microbeads so the principle
is that after dissociation you have your
mixture of human cells depicted here in
blue and all the different mouse cells
and these antibodies they recognize all
the mouse cells from all the different
tissues and all the different mouse
chains so if you run this over column
that is placed in the magnetic field you
will find your untouched human tumor
cells in the negative fraction if you
want you can also isolate
your mouse sets subsequently and this of
course has the advantage that is
completely independent on any positive
marker you need to know on your tumor
cells and therefore it works also for
all kind of different xenografts
even for non-tumor cells so for example
when you graft stem cells into the mouse
you can still get them back
and this is
when you take the cells in culture so if
you would just culture the original
infection what you see here is that you
have tumor cells that are growing on the
bed of fibroblasts and some other like
macrophages so if you would do a
functional essay on this here it is
would be very hard to dissect what
really comes from your killing of your
target cells and what comes as a bias
just from side effects from
contaminating cell populations whereas
when you isolate your tumor cells and
have to say that this whole method takes
only about 20 minutes then you start
with a pure population and of course
that would not only help you with car t
cells but also when you test biologicals
or small molecules
and then just to make the story a
complete also for the human tumors uh we
can isolate the tumor cells of course
here a little bit more difficult setting
because you want to isolate human tumor
cells out of the human lineage and um of
course when you ask yourself what are
the major contaminants it's of course
the red blood cells
the white blood cells the endothelial
cells and also the fibroblasts and again
we have developed an antibody cocktail
that you can just apply and also again
in 20 minutes get from such a crude
mixture of cells to purified tumor cells
and again if you compare these cultures
as expected
from the original infection you have a
mixture of tumor cells that are also in
many cases just overgrown after very few
days by fibroblasts whereas when you
isolate your tumor cells you can have a
clean culture that you can go on for
your functional assay
and this is not only possible for solid
tumor sums but also
let's say for very uh
challenging summits such as plural
effusion uh as shown here for ovarian
carcinoma because there you usually have
only one or two percent tumor cells but
still with the same method you can
isolate such tumor cells and also make
them applicable for functional
downstream analysis or essays
and again just the side note also we do
a lot of sequencing single cell
sequencing but also by sequencing and
what we've also seen but of course it
can be expected that when you isolate
your tumor cells and then do a whole
exome sequencing that was done in bulk
here uh of course you get also much
higher sensitivity in the detection of
somatic variants because you isolate
your tumor cells from subpopulation to a
pure population so you're not spending a
lot of reads on the cartridge of course
on sequencing cells that you're not
interested in and the same but even more
promising and dramatic holds true of
course for the single cell applications
so then you have isolated your tumor
cells and then you want to culture them
for the killing essay and again this is
very challenging but also for this we
have established a nice workflow
starting as mentioned dissociation
isolation of tumor cells if you want
then you can do the qc by flow cytometry
and then culture these cells either
short-term uh or to just plate them or
maybe a little bit longer term if you
want to expand them and here what i want
to point out is these are serum free
media and that has the big advantage
that um it is shown that um when you
culture tumor cells in media containing
high amounts of serum for prolonged
times these cells tend to differentiate
and also lose the tube initiating
capacity and this we avoid here so these
serum free media allow the culture of
tumor cells so far we have optimized
them for four indications colon
carcinoma renal clear cell cardio
ovarian carcinoma and pancreatic
carcinoma and if you compare for example
early and late passage you see that
there's a preservation of the
morphological heterogeneity we have also
done genetic analysis and flow cytometry
to really prove that this is kept and
what is also very nice when we look here
now again into pancreatic carcinoma that
you can derive it from primary tumors
but also from xenografts from unsorted
and isolated tumor cells but very nice
also you can
get adherent cell cultures but also
suspension cell cultures because we have
seen a trend that many epithelial tumors
tend to better grow in 3d and i have to
say that these are not embedded so these
are just purely grown as turmerics and
our media still nicely supply
them with everything they need to grow
in suspension turmeric 3d structures and
that is of course can be applied for
more complex co-culture models
and again what is very important and
this is data from the group of andreas
trump
which has initially developed this media
before working with us together on on
the further development and optimization
is that when you compare the patient
originating tumor to the patient you
have xenograft you see what you expect
you nicely resemble the morphology but
what is new now to these media is that
even when you culture them in 2d as
shown here and then re-graft them into a
immunodeficient mouse so a cell culture
deficient graft still you see nicely
resembling of the histological features
of the original tumor so they keep their
memory of where they are coming from and
also
look very similar to the pdx models and
that is of course giving you the chance
to also work on these cells and validate
everything later on on these cell line
derived casino graphs still
so with this now we have all the tools
in hand actually to also perform
functional car t-cell killing assays on
primary cells
and this is what we did and here just
some exemplary data and here you can see
aspc one which is established cell line
with expressing all the three markers
that we have talked about
but now you can also see cell and
derived from primary human tumors and
also from xenografts and now you see
also there's an array of different
expression patterns of our target
candidates as it would be in the reality
of clinical samples and so now you can
all use these kind of uh of primary
cultures and also co-culture them with
your car t-cells and really ask yourself
the question what
influences the cartesian activity is it
only the marker expression is it a
co-expression of
immunosuppressive molecules such as pl1
and
actually what you see it's very
dependent
on the target expression of course
because for example look at this this
part two uh cell line here
and if i go back to the flow cytometry
you see that this cell line only
expresses cd 318 but not the other
targets and as expected also when you
look here for markup regulation but also
cytokine release only cd 318 based cars
actually uh efficiently kill is a line
up regulate uh activation markers and
also release cytokines
and for example for the aspc-1
expressing all the targets you see also
killing of all the car t-sets and the
same holds true for this primary derived
cell line from a primary human tumor
so with this you can then also resemble
the heterogeneity in a clinical reality
and also what you see is it's not the
only case the target expression it's
also other factors
because also the cell line
activation pattern is not always at the
same level in each of these cell lines
so upon then
really nicely characterizing your
different car constructs you of course
choose the best working ones in vitro
and then you perform in vivo studies and
here we have used um
nsg xenograft models with other aspc one
or bx pc3 and we have injected then car
t cells and what you see here is on this
aspc one model uh that cd66s can uh
yeah can prolong survival of the mice
but it cannot eradicate the tumor and
the same holds true also here for the
speaks pc3 model i have to say that this
is very challenging both are very
challenging models because we already
established tumors for almost two weeks
so they are solid masses before we
inject iv the car t cells you see that
tspan8
in particular with the spacer shows a
very nice response with two more
clearing after about 30 days
uh but only in the aspc one not in the
pxbc3 model so here you all just need
too much stabilization for t-span8 and
this again can be uh dedicated to the
target expression evaluated by flow
cytometry also x vivo uh here you see t
span8 only very low express on the xbc3
very highly expressed on aspc one cells
and our let's say best candidate cd 318
you see very fast and efficient tumor
eradication even after less than two
weeks in both
models
so of course to better understand why a
car t cell is working or not and then we
do ex vivo analysis so we reject the the
tumor or tumor remnants and then we
check this by again the maxima
technology for cartesian infiltration
uh two more remnants macrophage
infiltration and target expression and
this is of course accomplished also by
in-depth flow cytometry analysis again
to look for potential explanations of
the indivo efficacy and for example what
you can see here is that actually cd6
function was not
low due to limit of target expression
because you see it's nicely expressed
even x vivo but it was a uh of obviously
a lack of uh functional car t cell
infiltration that you see in cd 318 but
not in 66 c so you see t cell
infiltration but not active infiltration
of these purple car t sets here
and of course
to make the story round we also do a lot
of phenotyping on the t cells isolated x
vivo
so we dissociate different organs like
the bone marrow the spleen but also the
tumor isolate based on cd45 positive
enrichment uh the car t cells and then
we do phenotyping and quantification of
the cars and their flow cytometry is of
course the method of choice because of
the very nice quantification you can do
but also we look at um
at ma central memory was effective
phenotypes because this was shown to
have predictive value later on for the
clinical efficiency when you go for
translation
the last point i want to make here is
that of course this is all either flow
cytometry or 2d spatial resolution but
you might also want to go deeper in the
tissue and also see the 3d context and
that is where we use light sheet
microscopy with our ultra microscopes
which actually give you the opportunity
so in this case we did the labeling even
in vivo so we injected the dyes into the
mice but you can also do it ex vivo then
you
take out the tumor or the organ of
interest you fix it you clear it in
order to make it amendable for um
for light sheet microscopy and now you
can really see here in green the tumor
cells in orange the vasculature and in
pink you see the car t cell infiltration
into the tumor and you can then of
course also make statistics about the
special distribution of these cells and
thereby derive much more information
about the persistence and proliferation
of the carti sets inside the tumors
so with this i want to thumb up and i
hope i could convince you that we have
provided a comprehensive workflow for
the identification of new target
candidates
here i focus today on car t-sets but
this is of course also applicable to
other
cellular therapies and also biologics
that we have developed solutions to
address all the technical challenges in
the functional evaluation of
immunotherapy targets in particular when
working with primary cells
and finally that we also identified four
target candidates for cellular
immunotherapy of pancreatic cancer
showing high tumor specificity very
restricted of tumor expression and i was
not talking about this
but you can also look it up in our
publication that was recently published
in nature medicine sorry in nature
communications about the confident
bioinformatics safety level
and we were able to derive functional
car constructs in vitro and in vivo
so with this i want to thank the people
that really do the work because i'm just
sitting in the office and waiting for
nice data but this is really
dedicated to the people in my team
that compiled all the data worked on
this and also a lot of multimedia
colleagues because it was a big
interdisciplinary project with
bioinformatics
our t-cell experts and many others
but also cooperation partners in
academia and also industry and of course
also you for your attention